AND ROSEANNE CANCELED AFTER ROSE
ROSEANNE’S COMMENTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT GAVE A ROUSING
SPEECH IN TENNESSEE.
FRIEND OF THE SHOW MARSHA
BLACKBURN, WE’LL PLAY YOU THE
BEST MOMENTS OF THE RALLY TRIEWT
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
FIRST TALKS WITH KIM JUNG UN,
TALKS IN THE BALANCE, WE HAVE
FULL HOPE ABOUT THE UPCOMING
TALKS.
TOMORROW, SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO, A MASSIVE
DEVELOPMENT, THE LATEST SIGN
THAT THE HISTORIC TALKS MAY TAKE
PLACE IN SINGAPORE SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN JUNE 12TH.
THE PRESIDENT SENT A STRONGLY
UNAFTER HE FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
BASIC PLANNING AHEAD OF THE
TALKS.
YOUR CORRUPT MEDIA USED THE
LETTER TO BASH THE PRESIDENT.
IN ORDER TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT
FAIL, THAT MEANS THE COUNTRY HAS
TO FAIL.
THEY ARE OPENLY ROOTING FOR THE
COUNTRY TO FAIL, EVEN IF A MORE
PEACEFUL WORLD IS AT STAKE FOR
OUR CHILDREN.
WATCH THE DESPICABLE DISPLAY.
>> A FRIEND OF MINE SENT AN
E-MAIL TO ME ON THE TRAIN TO NEW
YORK.
SOUNDS LIKE A BREAK UP LETTER
FROM OVERNIGHT CAMP.
>> I’M GOING TO BREAK UP WITH
YOU BEFORE YOU BREAK UP WITH ME,
BUT CALL ME.
>> LAST WEEK A TEAM IN SINGAPORE
STOOD UP ON A DATE, GHOSTED BY
NORTH KOREA, NOT EVEN RESPONDING
TO U.S. OVERTURES AND NOW THE
BREAK UP LETTER AND THREAT OF
USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> HE DICTATES THIS BIZARRE
LETTER.
>> IT’S A TOTAL BREAK UP LETTER.
WHEN YOUR RELATIONSHIP STARTS
SOURING, YOU CUT IT OFFICER.
OFF FIRST.
>> EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA, THEY
ARE ALL SHEEP.
THEY HAVE AN ECHO CHAMBER AND
QUOTE THEMSELVES.
WHILE THE MEDIA IS QUICK TO BASH
THE PRESIDENT IN NEGOTIATION,
THEY NEED TO LEARN THE ART OF
THE DEAL, WHILE THEY ARE HAPPY
TO IGNORE THE PRESIDENT’S
HISTORIC TRIUMPHS, SUCCESS
FREEING 17 AMERICANS ONCE
DETAINED OR HELD HOSTAGE ABROAD.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SECURED
THE RELEASE OF JOSHUA HOTEL AND
HIS WIFE AFTER BEING DETAINED ON
SEVERAL BOGUS CHARGES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I’M OVERWHELMED WITH
GRATITUDE FOR YOU GUYS, FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE DONE,
FOR THE SUPPORT OF MY WIFE FOR
TWO YEARS, VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
TWO YEARS.
SO GRATEFUL FOR WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE.
FOR THINKING ABOUT ME AND CARING
ABOUT ME, A NORMAL PERSON.
IT TOUCHES ME.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN VERY BRAVE,
ACTUALLY.
WE SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING INSIDE
THAT PRISON, SO YOU HAVE BEEN
VERY, VERY BRAVE.
>> THANK GOD OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS ARE HOME.
WE HAVE MORE ON THE PRESIDENT’S
GAINS AROUND THE WORLD.
WE HAVE MORE FROM ROBERT
MUELLER’S DISTURBING RUN AWAY
WITCH HUNT.
WE REPORTED THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION UTILIZED AT LEAST
ONE INFORMANT TO SPY ON MULTIPLE
PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY’LL BE HERE TONIGHT ALONG
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPULOS.
THE INFORMANT FBI SPY USED HIM
TO SECURE THE MEETING WITH
PAPADOPULOS.
FORMER CAMPAIGN AD MICHAEL, ALL
THREE APPROACHED BY THE SPY JOIN
US TONIGHT.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND IF THERE
WERE SPIES IN HILLARY’S CAMPAIGN
AND SHE DID DO A DEAL FOR
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I KNOW
FOR A FACT, THIS PERSON THEY
TRIED TO PLANT IN THE CAMPAIGN
AND ADMINISTRATION, HE’S NOT THE
ONLY PERSON THAT CAME WITH THE
CAMPAIGN AND THE OBAMA CAMPAIGN
CAME AT ME.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> EVEN FORMER ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY ANDY MCARTY IS BACKING
UP SOME OF THESE CLAIMS, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
HYPOCRITICAL PRETEXT.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DECIDED
TO USE THE COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
POWERS  TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN USING ELECTRONIC
MONITORING AND INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING TACTICS.
IT IGNORED THE NORM AGAINST
POLITICAL OPPONENTS, NOT BASED
ON EVIDENCE OF A TRUMP RUSSIAN
CONSPIRACY, BUT SPECULATION
ABOUT THE RUSSIAN CONTACTS AND
SYMPATHIES.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I SAID THEY
ARE WEAPON NICING THE POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE.
THIS UNPRECEDENTED SPYING IS
BEING USED BY TEAM MUELLER TO
MALIGN THE PRESIDENT AND THOSE
AROUND HIM.
THE PRESIDENT RAISED ANOTHER
CONCERN ABOUT THE ONGOING
MUELLER WITCH HUNT.
13 DEMOCRATS PLUS PEOPLE THAT
WORKED EIGHT YEARS FOR OBAMA
WILL MEDDLE WITH THE MIDTERMS
NOW THAT THE REPUBLICS ARE
TAKING THE LEAD IN THE POLLS.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION BUT BY
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT RAISES CONCERN
GIVEN THE NEW REVELATION THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS CAUSING RIGHTLY
SPY GATE.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS ACTIVELY
TRYING TO FIND ANYTHING ON THIS
PRESIDENT.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN DOING
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
DOWNPLAY WHAT IS THEE SINGLE
ABUSE OF POWER CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN POLITICS AND
HISTORY.
YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION USING
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO SPY ON
AN OPPOSING POLITICAL PARTY
DURING A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
USING BOUGHT AND PAID FOR, THE
OTHER CAMPAIGN IN THIS CASE,
HILARY CLINTON, USING HER BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR MONEY TO HIRE A
FOREIGN NATIONAL TO GET RUSSIAN
LIES THAT HE SAYS IN AN
INTERROG.TORY IN GREAT BRITAIN
INTELLIGENCE TO GET A FIZA JUDGE
AND NOT TELLING ANY THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR IT.
LOOK HOW THE BIASED PRESS IS
TRYING TO BRUSH ASIDE THIS HUGE
NATIONAL CORRUPTION SCANDAL.
>> LET’S FOR THE SAKE OF
DISCUSSION USE THE TERM SPY, THE
USE OF TRADE CRAFT, USING A
FORMALLY TRAINED CASE OFFICER
WHO WOULD MASK IDENTITY, ATTEMPT
TO RECRUIT.
NONE OF THE ATTRIBUTES OF SPY
CRAFT WERE PRESENT HERE.
THIS IS THE MOST BENIGN FORM OF
INFORMATION GATHERING.
TO CHARACTERIZE IT AS A SPY OR
SPY GATE IS PART OF THE
NARRATIVE.
IT’S DIRECTLY NOT WHAT I SAID.
>> THE POINT NOW IS THAT HE’S
USING THEM TO A PARTICULAR KIND
OF EFFECT.
>> HE’S A LIBERAL HACK AND
CLAPPER IS A KNOWN LIAR.
WE HAVE MORE ON THE COMPLICIT
MEDIA’S COVER UP THROUGH THE
SHOW.
NOW TO A STORY THAT LEFT MANY ON
THE LEFT EMBARRASSED OVER THE
WEEKEND.
REMEMBER THIS PICTURE SHOWING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DETAINED IN A
CHAIN LINK FENCE.
MANY ON THE LEFT BECAME
OUTRAGED.
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS HELD IN
CAGES LIKE DOGS.
HASH TAGGING, WE ARE OUR
CHILDREN.
KING AND YOUR FRIENDS IN THE
MEDIA FAILED TO REALIZE -- PUT
THE PICTURES BACK UP.
THEY WERE TAKEN 2014.
BARACK OBAMA WAS YOUR PRESIDENT.
BACK THEN, THEY VOICED ZERO
CONCERN ABOUT OBAMA’S DETENTION
POLICIES.
OTHERS ON THE LEFT USED THE
PHOTOS ATTACK PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT CORRECTLY
POINTS OUT THE PHOTO IS FROM
2014.
THAT SHOWS HOW HIGHLIGHTED THE
DISCUSSION HAS BECOME.
>> RENEWED SCRUTINY, SOME
CHILDREN ARE BEING SEPARATED
FROM THE CHILDREN AT THE BORDER.
ONE OF HIS FAVORITE TOPICS,
IMMIGRATION.
THIS AS HIS POLICIES FACE MAJOR
CRITICISM, DEMS MUST AGREE TO
WALL AND BORDER PROTECTION FOR
COUNTRY.
BI-PARTISAN BILL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TAKING
SERIOUS HEAT RECENTLY,
PARTICULARLY HIS POLICY OF
SEPARATING FAMILIES IN
DETENTION.
>> THERE IS A NEW POLICY FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION TO SEPARATE
FAMILIES, FAMILIES THAT MADE THE
COURAGEOUS DECISION, THE HARD
DECISION TO LEAVE BEHIND
EVERYTHING THEY HAD, THEIR
COMMUNITY, THEIR BELONGINGS, OUT
OF FEAR.
>> THE SITCOM OF ROSEANNE HAS
BEEN CANCELED AFTER ROSEANNE BAR
MADE COMMENTS ABOUT ’BAMA AIDE.